a big moment in Parliament's five-year
cycle as M eps test the fitness of
jean-claude yonkers college of 27 would
be commissioners a chance to to shape
the e use executive branch as it steers
important legislation on for example
trade energy climate and data protection
it was no easy ride for any of them and
for one the end of the road out alenka
bratusek former Slovenian Prime Minister
up for energy union as a vice president
the problems lack of knowledge vagueness
self nomination slovenia nominated
Violetta boots as replacement she's a
former telecoms entrepreneur with a
colorful background newly recruited to
politics her hearing takes place on
Monday along with Slovak Mara chef
kovitch who mr. Jung ko na wants for the
energy portfolio with ms boots in
transport shaky several candidates who
were pressed hard including T born of
Iraq six former Hungarian Foreign
Minister up for Education and Culture
mep s were troubled by media
restrictions adopted by Hungary's
right-wing government some were found
wanting after the first hearing notably
Jonathan Hill the UK's nomination for
financial services that was concerned
about his past PR links to financial
institutions and me well arias Kenyatta
Spain's nomination for climate and
energy he had to file more answers to
more questions as did Pierre Moscovici
the former French finance minister for
most M eps though the majority produced
shining performances politically astute
and fully across their briefs so how did
it all compared with previous hearings
over 22 veterans of the process there
are moral inattention I believe when
they come because they know how
difficult it is and how much it requests
from from them to be ahead of the
dossier of their portfolio even if they
come from another background but also
it's a a test for them in their aptitude
how they will be able to tackle their
portfolio in political terms in the last
term we looked into the details what
does a political targets this time it
was against the people against a
candidate it
elf and it was a kind of moping and
stalking and I think that was something
which I don't agree and so for the next
hearing maybe we should sink that not
every country only gives one candidate
maybe we should have three candidates
where next 10 mr. jonker will be hoping
for confirmations by M eps on Monday so
he can present his college two days
later and the new commission can start
work as foreseen on November the first